AT EIGHT,
>> THE SHOW THAT IS THE SWORN
ENEMY OF LYING, POMPOSITY,
SMUGNESS, AND GROUPTHINK.
>> Sean: TUCKER, AND OTHER
BREAKING NEWS NIGHT, A LOT OF
GROUND TO COVER, MOMENTS AGO AS
YOU JUST SAW AT THE END OF
TUCKER, HIS MASSIVE RALLY IN
HERSHEY, PENNSYLVANIA, AS PER
USUAL THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
LINING UP OUTSIDE IN THE
FREEZING COLD AND RAIN TO GET A
SPOT INSIDE THE ARENA.
FROM SUPPORT TO REPORTERS,
CLEARLY MOTIVATED.
MAYBE THE MEDIA IS NOT NOTICING.
IN FACT, THE PRESIDENT IS
PULLING WELL AHEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS IN THESE
KEY SWING STATES, PENNSYLVANIA,
WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN AND OTHER
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THOSE NUMBERS
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
PROGRAM.
PLUS, WE WILL HAVE ACTION TO THE
DEMOCRATS AND SANITY.
UKRAINIAN CONSPIRACY THEORY,
IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPT AND HOW
ILLEGITIMATE AND FRANKLY ALMOST
LAUGHABLE WHAT IT HAS NOW
DESCENDED INTO COME ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
WE WILL TRY TO DO THE IMPOSSIBLE
IN DETAIL EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
LIE FROM THAT GUY.
WE WILL EXPOSE HIM.
HE IS COMPROMISED, CORRUPT AND A
GENERAL LAYER APPEARED WEAK
TONIGHT WE PROVE IT.
BUT FIRST AS WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU OVER TWO AND HALF
YEARS, OUR TOP STORY TONIGHT THE
SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL, CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN POLITICAL HISTORY, OUR
COUNTRY'S MOST POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE WERE WEAPONIZED
AGAINST A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, 18, AND
ALL 2016-2017.
WE WILL WRITE FROM A TRIP
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WAS RIGHT.
SPYING OCCURRED.
WE TOLD YOU THE MOB DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT, BUT IT IS ALL TRUE.
TAKE A LOOK.
DO YOU STILL STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT THAT THE CAMPAIGN WAS
SPIED UPON?
>> IT WAS CLEARLY SPIED UPON.
THAT IS THE SURVEILLANCES.
WIRING PEOPLE LEFT TO GO IN AND
TALK TO PEOPLE AND MAKE
RECORDINGS OF THE CONVERSATIONS,
SPYING.
I THINK GOING THROUGH PEOPLE'S
EMAILS, WHICH THEY DID AS A
RESULT OF THE FISA WARRANT.
THEY DID EVERYTHING FROM PAGE'S
LIFE.
>> SHE WAS IN AT THE CAMPAIGN AT
THAT POINT.
>> YES, I THINK FEMALES WERE
HELD BACK.
>> Sean: THE MOB AND THE MEDIA
CHASE THEIR OWN TAIL OBSESSING
ABOUT ONE HOAX AND CONSPIRACY
AFTER ANOTHER.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM, WE NEVER
RELENTED.
WE IMPALED EVERY LAYER OF THE
YOUNG END.
WE COVER THIS VERY REAL ABUSE OF
POWER, THIS REAL CORRUPTION
SCANDAL AND PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
IN HISTORY FROM A SCANDAL THAT
NOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES JUST CALLED
INTOLERABLE.
HE IS RIGHT.
THESE ARE POWERFUL COMMENTS.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
THESE COMMENTS ARE NOT MADE IN A
VACUUM.
THIS IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE KNOWS MORE THAN ALL OF US.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WAY THINK IT'S NATION WAS
TURNED ON ITS HEAD FOR THREE
YEARS.
AND BASED ON A COMPLETELY BOGUS
NARRATIVE THAT LARGELY FANNED
AND HYPED BY A RESPONSIBLE
PRESS.
AND I THINK THERE WERE GROSS
ABUSES OF FISA AND INEXPLICABLE
BEHAVIOR THAT IS INTOLERABLE TO
ME, THE FBI.
>> Sean: LET ME REPEAT, TWO
AND A HALF YEARS OUR ENSEMBLE
CAST, WE GOT THE BEAT OUT OF US
EVERY DAY.
NO, WE WERE MADE FUN OF AND IT'S
OKAY I DON'T CARE WHAT PEOPLE
SAY ANYMORE.
YOU, ME COME WITH THE PEOPLE WE
WERE RIGHT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
AND THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FISA
REPORT CONFIRMED AND REBUILD
MAJOR FACTS, ONE, AND WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU HILLARY CLINTON
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
IT WAS CENTRAL, IT WAS
ESSENTIAL.
IT WAS ALMOST THE ENTIRE FISA
APPLICATION AGAINST CARTER PAGE,
THE BACK DOOR INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TRANSITION TEAM AND
EVEN PRESIDENCY.
WITHOUT THE DIRTY DOSSIER, AS WE
TOLD YOU, IT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
A FISA WARRANT HERE AT THE
SO-CALLED INTELLIGENT IN THE
DOSSIER WAS NOTHING BUT GARBAGE,
LIES, CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND
COOPERATED THE GARBAGE BASED ON
ONE SINGLE SOURCE.
NEVER COOPERATED TO COOPERATED,
NEVER VERIFIED, IN FACT, AS WE
TOLD YOU, IT WAS UNVERIFIABLE.
THIRD, THE DOSSIER'S AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE SAID, HIS
SINGLE SOURCE WAS EGOMANIAC THAT
LIKED TO BOAST.
FOURTH, STEALS A SINGLE SOURCE
TOLD THE FBI HIS OR HER CLAIMS
WERE NEVER COOPERATED, NEVER
CONCLUSIVE AND BASED OFF
OF WORD-OF-MOUTH, HEARSAY AND A
CRUDE JOKE AT THE BAR,
ESPECIALLY THE, MOSCOW RIDGE
CARLTON?
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION TOTALLY
ADMITTED FROM THE PFIZER
APPLICATIONS ON PURPOSE.
THAT WOULD BE PREMEDITATED
FRAUD, PERPETRATED REPEATEDLY ON
THE FISA COURT.
ACCORDING TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THERE WERE AT
LEAST 17 SIGNIFICANT FAILURES,
INACCURACIES AND OMISSIONS.
BY THE WAY, HATE, SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY, THAT IS YOUR FBI,
THAT IS YOU.
YOU DID THAT!
YOU HEARD THE PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OF THE
WORLD.
NOT THE RANKING FILED.
THEY ARE FANTASTIC.
YOU SIGNED OFF ON THREE OF THE
FOUR FISA APPLICATIONS.
YOU NEVER VERIFIED IT BECAUSE IT
WAS UNVERIFIABLE.
YOU KNEW FULL WELL THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED WAS NEVER
SUPPOSED TO BE VETTED, TRUE OR
ACCURATE AND THAT IT WAS
UNVERIFIABLE.
AND UNDER COMEY 'CORRUPT
LEADERSHIP HIGH-RANKING FBI
OFFICIALS COME AGAIN NOT THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN AND THE
BEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE WORLD, THOSE TOP GUYS KNOWIG
THE WORLD, THOSE TOP GUYS KNOWIY
MISLED THAT FISA REPORT
REPEATEDLY.
THEY KNOWINGLY AND PURPOSELY, WE
LEARNED YESTERDAY AND TODAY
AT -- OMITTED EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION.
THE RELIABILITY OF STEELE'S
PRINCIPAL SOURCE.
THEY ALTERED THINGS AND AG BARR
SANK COMEY, THE FBI, WELL, THEY
MAY HAVE BEEN BEEN ACTING IN BAD
FAITH.
THAT IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT TELL
THE COURT WHAT THEY HAD BEEN
RELYING ON WAS COMPLETELY IN A
RUBBISH, THEY ACTUALLY STARTED
SAYING THINGS TO BOLSTER THE
REPORT BY SAYING WE TALK TO THE
SOURCES AND THEY APPEAR TO BE
TRUTHFUL.
OKAY, YOU INFORMED THE COURT
WHAT THEY ARE TRUTHFUL ABOUT,
THE DOSSIER IS FULL SPIRIT SO
THAT IS HARD TO EXPLAIN.
AND THE CORE STATEMENT, IN MY
OPINION, BY THE IG, IS THAT
THESE IRREGULARITIES, THESE
STATEMENTS, THESE OMISSIONS ARE
NOT SATISFACTORILY EXPLAINED.
AND I THINK THAT LEAVES OPEN THE
POSSIBILITY TO INFER BAD FAITH.
>> Sean: WHAT IS BARR SAYING
HERE?
COMEY IS LIKELY A SUBJECT IN THE
DURHAM/BARR PROBE?
HE DIDN'T GET THE MEMO BECAUSE
MR. SUPER PATRIOT TAKING A
VICTORY LAP LIVING IN'S
CONSPIRACY WORLD AND CRAZY HOME
COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP.
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
MR. COMEY, I WARNED YOU ABOUT
THIS BEFORE IT.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO HOLD OFF ON
POPPING THE CHAMPAGNE.
AND GUESS WHAT, YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
I SUGGEST YOU MIGHT WANT TO DO
THAT.
WE HAVE A CLEAR PATTERN NOW OF
WILLFUL MISCONDUCT.
COMEY, BRENNAN, CLAPPER AND ALL
THESE OTHER TOP OFFICIALS IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
ONE OF THE MOST PIECES OF
EVIDENCE IS THE FACT THAT NO ONE
INSIDE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THEY
NEVER WENT TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, CANDIDATE TRUMP IS A
PATRIOT AND WANT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ABOUT THIS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
NO.
LET'S SEE BRENNAN WENT TO THE
RUSSIANS TWICE AND OBAMA WENT
WANTS TO TELL THEM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT I FIND PARTICULARLY
INEXPLICABLE IS THAT THEY TALK
TO THE RUSSIANS.
BUT NOT TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
ON AUGUST 4TH, BRENNAN AHEAD OF
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE, HE CALLS
THE HEAD OF RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
AND WE KNOW WHAT YOU'RE UP TO.
YOU BETTER STOP IT.
HE DID IT LATER IN AUGUST AND
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA TALKED TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND SEPTEMBER
AND SAID, WE KNOW WHAT YOU'RE UP
TO.
YOU BETTER CUT IT OUT.
SO THEY GO AND CONFRONT THE
RUSSIANS WHO CLEARLY ARE THE BAD
GUYS, AND THEY WON'T GO AND TALK
AND SAY WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> Sean: I WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE ELECTION.
INSTEAD OF BRIEFING THE
PRESIDENT, HIS CAMPAIGN AT THE
TIME REMEMBERS ON HIS TEAM ABOUT
A POSSIBLE THREAT.
THIS IS PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE.
BRENNAN, OBAMA, OTHERS, COMEY
USED THEIR MEETINGS WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND TRANSITION
TEAM SECRETLY COLLECTING
EVIDENCE ON TRUMPET AND WARNING
THE RUSSIANS.
A SET UP, AN INSURANCE POLICY
FROM THE GET-GO.
BUT LET NOT YOUR HEARTS BE
TROUBLED BECAUSE CLEARLY
SPEAKING OUT FOR A REASON.
THEY OBVIOUSLY, NOT HARD TO
FIGURE OUT THE MINOT THINGS WE
DO NOT KNOW.
AND THEY ARE NOW OFFICIAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BEYOND
SERIOUS.
AND I WOULD BELIEVE JUSTICE IS
ABOUT TO BE SERVED.
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
I'M NOT MAKING ANY TIME
PREDICTIONS BECAUSE, WELL, I
THOUGHT THE HOROWITZ REPORT
WOULD BE OUT LAST MAY.
AND TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT HAS
EVERY REASON TO BE CONFIDENT